meghan markle speaks out after winning
her privacy court case let's talk about
this for a second on thursday the court
of appeal in london ruled in favor of
the 40-year-old duchess of sussex after
a lengthy legal battle with associated
newspapers the publishers of the mail on
sunday in terms of this
the appeal i won the case and this issue
frankly has been going on
when i had no children at all so it's an
arduous process the decision means the
case will not proceed to trial and that
megan is now due financial damages as
well as a public apology that will
appear on the front page of the mail on
sunday and the home page of the mail
online let's not forget the sussex said
they wanted to leave the uk to avoid the
intrusion of the british media the case
originally stemmed from the outlet
printing parts of a private letter meg
wrote to her estranged father thomas
markle in 2018. and on thursday the
judge found that quote the contents of
the letter were private and concerned
personal matters that were not matters
of legitimate public interest following
the news megan released a statement
calling the ruling a quote victory not
just for her but quote anyone who has
ever felt scared to stand up for what's
right she went on stating in part
what matters most is that we are now
collectively brave enough to reshape a
tabloid industry that conditions people
to be cruel and profits from the lies
and pain that they create it's a
sentiment megan shared while speaking at
the new york times deal book online
summit last month well first i would
urge you not to read tabloids hopefully
one day they come with a warning label
like cigarettes do like this is toxic
for your mental health associate
newspapers also reacted to the judgment
in a statement thursday saying that they
are quote very disappointed and are
quote considering an appeal to the
supreme court in the united kingdom of
course this all comes after a high court
judge in london ruled earlier this year
that the british tabloid parent company
invaded megan's privacy she'd been
through a high court case against the
mail on sunday she won that privacy
court case so a big victory for megan
last month the publisher launched an
official challenge against that verdict
at the uk's court of appeal and at the
time meg opened up about the court saga
saying that no matter what she will
continue to follow her moral compass
it's just me standing up for what's
right which i think is important across
the board and point no matter how
difficult it is you know the difference
between right and wrong you must stand
up for what's right and that's what i'm
doing